The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Very good.
So today, we'll
begin with a study
of one dimensional potentials
and the energy eigenstates
or properties.
And we'll discuss this for
about half of the lecture.
And then go into the
variational principle.
So let me go back then to
our discussion of last time,
where we were talking
about energy eigenstates
and the Schrodinger
equation in one dimension.
So there's a term that
we use all the time.
This term is called
the bound state.
And bound state seems something
sort of very non-trivial.
But mathematically, we can
say quite clearly what it is.
A bound state is
something that is not
spread all over
space, basically.
And the way we therefore use
the terminology for bound
state it that we only
speak of bound states
when there are
energy eigenstates.
So an energy eigenstate may
or may not be a bound state,
but any bound state is
an energy eigenstate.
So an energy eigenstate
is a bound state
if the wave function
goes to zero
when you go
sufficiently far away.
So it's a simple
definition, but it
helps us understand
that the basic idea is
at the state is just not
spread all over the world.
Now remember we're trying
to find energy eigenstates,
and that is to find
wave functions, time
independent wave functions,
that solve the time
independent
Schrodinger equation.
Which I have written
there for convenience.
This is the same equation
we wrote last time.
For a time
independent potential,
so that the full
wave function can
be written as a
phase that contains
the information of the
energy times a function of x,
sine of x.
That still may be complex, but
it doesn't have to be complex.
As you can see, this
is a real equation.
Now in order to clean up some of
the constants in this equation,
it's-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is
it not V x minus e?
PROFESSOR: Well you have to
look back at the Schrodinger
equation, and bring the
things to the other side,
and take care of the signs.
It is correct as stated.
Check it.
Now we have, in order
to do this and just
to write things with
a little more clarity,
we scale the energy.
So we define a
calligraphic energy,
which is 2m over h squared times
energy E. And a calligraphic V
with the same scaling factor.
So that the Schrodinger
equation then takes the form--
this same equation-- sine.
And I'll use the double prime
notation for two derivatives.
Plus now E minus cal
of x sine equals zero.
So this is how our
equation looks.
It's relatively simple.
And can be treated
without carrying constants
all over the place.
Now we're going to
discuss a few results that
are extremely important that
you keep in mind for the future.
It helps you think clearly.
So these results are
little theorems that I'm
going to state.
And the proofs are
given in the notes.
I will skip some of
the proofs, although I
will tell you what the
strategy is for the proofs
and then show how
the theorem implies,
as a corollary,
interesting things that
could easily be misconstrued.
So let me give you
the first theorem.
Theorem one.
This is just the
statement that if you
are talking about bound states
in one dimensional potentials,
there are no degeneracies.
So let's write it.
There is no degeneracy
for bound states of one
dimensional potentials.
So it's a fundamental result.
We'll see some way to
understand it a little later.
And you have seen this
in 804, I believe.
So what is a
strategy to a proof?
So we want a rigorous proof.
So what is a strategy?
I will not go through the proof.
The strategy is to assume
there is a degeneracy.
So strategy, assume
a degeneracy.
So sine 1 and sine 2 different
with the same energy.
And then you write this
equation for sine 1 and sine 2,
and they have the same energy.
Then you take the two equations,
and you multiply the first
by something, the
second by another thing.
Subtract it.
Do a bit of algebra.
And you suddenly can
prove that one solution
is equal to a constant
times the other solution.
So you do the work, and
that's what comes out.
Once you've shown that one
is proportional to the other,
we've declared in
quantum mechanics
that two wave functions
that differ by a constant
have exactly the same physics.
You can normalize it,
and normalize them.
And the constant
can be just a phase,
but the phase doesn't matter.
So those two wave functions
are really the same.
So you get a contradiction.
You thought they were different.
But the difference
is just too trivial,
and therefore they are really
the same wave function.
Because we've said that
two wave functions that
differ by a constant
should be identified.
So that's this theorem.
And it's a key theorem.
Let's go to the next theorem
that is also important.
So theorem two.
Energy eigenstates sine f of
x can be chosen to be real.
So here it is.
We mentioned that this
differential equation
allows for real solutions.
There's no contradiction,
because there's no i in there.
But now we say more.
That even if you find
a complex solution,
you can work with
real solutions.
So what is the strategy here?
Again strategy.
To have you get a
complex solution.
Sine f of x.
And then you go about
to prove that actually
this complex solution
implies the existence of two
real solutions.
So this complex solution
implies existence
of two real solutions.
And moreover, two real-- I
should say it better here--
degenerate solutions.
How could you prove that?
Well, it probably
would occur to you
that you would take a solution
and say, oh, this solves it.
Then you would show that sine
star also solves this equation.
And then by linearity of
the Schrodinger equation,
you could form what we would
call the real solution formed
by taking sine plus sine
star and adding them.
Or the real solution that
comes from the imaginary part.
You see the real and imaginary
parts of a complex number
are real.
So is the case here as well.
That they can take sine and
sine star that are different.
And the sum is real
by construction.
You put the star, and
recalling that star of star
gives nothing, you see that this
function is equal to its star.
So it's real.
So is this one.
This function, which is the
imaginary part of the solution
that you had, is also real.
So you get two real solutions.
Moreover, you can show
that sine and sine star
have the same energy.
Therefore sine r and sine
m have the same energy.
So I'm really
skipping very little.
But I don't want to
clutter the blackboard
with the whole derivation
at this moment.
So here is the strategy.
A complex solution implies
two real solutions.
And therefore, since
you have real solutions,
you can always choose
them to be real.
No loss of generality.
You had a complex solution.
You say, I like
just real solutions.
And you chose your
two real solutions.
You give them.
You've given the whole thing.
But then there is
a nice corollary
for the case of one
dimension bound states.
So this is the part that is
perhaps somewhat interesting.
And the corollary
is that if you're
talking bound states
of one dimension,
any solution is equal to a
real solution up to a constant.
You may say, well
what's the difference?
Let's write it down
and look at it.
Corollary for bound states of
one dimensional potentials.
Any solution is, up to a phase,
equal to a real solution.
So how does that go?
Maybe we can use more
of this blackboard.
Why would any solution
be, up to a phase,
equal to a real solution?
OK.
Suppose you have these
two solutions here.
Well this is real, so
that's trivially true.
And this is real.
But what if I put a linear
combination of them?
Or take the original
complex solution?
Why would it be, up to a phase,
equal to a real solution?
The answer is the following.
Because of theorem and,
that there's no degeneracy,
you've got two
solutions that claim
to be different and degenerate.
But that can't be.
So by theorem one, you must
have that-- in the notations,
I have here-- sine
imaginary of x
must be equal to a constant
times sine real of x.
Now if these function's
anyway are real,
the constant here must be real.
Therefore, even if you form
the original complex solution,
sine, which is sine real
plus i sine imaginary.
You can check that.
It's clear by definition that
that's the way it should be.
If you think this, this
is equal to 1 plus i times
c times sine real of x.
Therefore this is equal
to a constant times
the phase of-- this
is a complex number.
So this is yet another
constant that we
could say, the norm of 1 plus
i c times some phase times sine
r of x.
So you see that any solution,
any linear combination,
in fact, with any numbers of
sine r and sine imaginary,
will be a constant times
a phase times this thing.
So it is really
just real anyway.
So you can just
have one solution.
And any solution
that you may write,
that represents a bound
state, is, up to a phase,
equal to a real solution.
OK.
So that's our theorem two.
Theorem three.
It's also very famous.
If the potential V of x is
even-- that is, V of minus x
is equal to V of x-- the
eigenstate can be chosen
to be even or odd
under x2 minus x.
OK.
So here is another claim.
So the potential is even.
There's no theorem for
all the potentials.
No clear theorems, no simple
theorems for all the--
but if the potential
is even, the claim
is that you can choose
eigenstates to be even or odd.
The word chosen is
very important here.
Otherwise, this would not
be a precise statement.
You cannot say the
eigenstates are even or odd.
You can choose them to be.
So how does the proof go?
Strategy begin with
a wave function,
sine of x, that is
neither even nor odd.
And then you do a little work
with the Schrodinger equation.
Take the Schrodinger
equation, change all x's
to minus x's and show that,
in fact, not only is sine
of x a solution, but sine of
minus x is also a solution.
With the same energy.
So prove that sine of
minus x is a solution
with the same energy.
And in this case, of
course, we can already
have shown that we
can choose these wave
functions to be real.
So we can choose all of these
wave functions to be real.
And what do we do next?
If we have these two solutions
with the same energy,
then you can build
of sine s, which
is 1/2 of sine of x
plus sine of minus x.
And of sine a.
s for symmetric, and
a for anti-symmetric.
And of sine a,
that is 1/2 of sine
of x minus sine of minus x.
And this tool
would be this even,
under the exchange
of x for minus x.
This one odd, under the
exchange of x for minus x.
And both would be
solutions by superposition.
And both would have
the same energy.
So that's the end of the theorem
because then these things are
even or odd and have
the same energy.
So the solutions can be chosen
to be even or odd under x.
So if you've proven this,
you've got it already.
But now we get the corollary.
For bound states
in one dimension,
the solutions not
anymore the word chosen.
We can delete the word chosen.
The solutions are
either odd or even.
So it's a lot stronger.
It's not anymore, you
can choose them to be,
but a general one is
neither odd nor even.
No.
You try to find the solution
that is neither odd nor even,
and you can't find it.
So it's very strong.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is this
for even potentials?
PROFESSOR: Even potentials.
Yes.
For bound states in one
dimension with even potentials.
V of x.
V of minus x equal V of x.
Yes.
So how do we show that?
Well, again, you've
got two solutions here
that are degenerate that
have the same energy.
Sine of x and sine of minus x.
So given that there's
no degeneracy in one
dimensional problems, this thing
that they have the same energy,
the only thing that
can be happening
is that sine of minus x is equal
to a constant times sine of x.
Where this constant is real.
Why real?
Because we said already
by the previously theorem,
wave functions can
be chosen to be real.
So you've got this thing
already that this is true.
Sine of minus x is equal
to c times sine of x.
Which, if you use this
property again by saying,
oh, but sine of x is equal
to c times sine of minus x.
Basically, what this says
is that you can change
the sign of the argument
by putting an extra c.
So you do it again, sine
of x is equal to this.
So this is c squared
times sine of minus x.
So c squared must be equal to 1.
And therefore c is equal
to either plus or minus 1.
No other option.
So the functions are
either even or odd,
but they can't be arbitrary.
This point is
sufficiently settled
that part two
general exam at MIT
10 years ago had a
question like that.
And the person that
invented the problem
claimed that there
would be a solution that
could be neither even nor odd.
So even faculty members at
MIT sometimes get this wrong.
It's not as weak as
this, that can be chosen.
But it's really either
or other in the case
you have one dimension.
OK.
So these are our main theorems.
And we're going to
proceed now by clarifying
a little more the
nature of the spectrum.
So are there questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you give
an example of state
that's not bound?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The question is can
I give an example
of a state that is not bound?
Yes.
We can give such state.
You have a potential like this.
And you have an
energy like that.
And then the wave function
could look like this.
Then do something like that.
And then look like that.
It just doesn't vanish
when you go to infinity.
AUDIENCE: So that
can't be normalized?
PROFESSOR: Can't be normalized.
That's right.
If it's not bound, it
can't be normalized.
Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you can't really
represent-- it's doesn't really
represent single particles,
more like a stream of particles?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So it doesn't represent
a single particle.
Now trying to interpret it
as a stream of particles
is a little delicate.
So what we usually do is
we build superpositions
of those states that can
represent a localized thing.
But it's true that,
morally speaking,
it seems to represent
more than one particle.
OK.
So now we talk a little about
the nature of the spectrum.
So what do we want to say here?
We want to go back to the
Schrodinger equation here.
And just move one term
to the right hand side.
And just see what
can happen in terms
of singularities
and discontinuities.
So first of all, we
always begin with the idea
that sine must be continuous.
And the reason sine
must be continuous is
that we don't want
singularities worse
than delta functions
in potentials.
If a function is
continuous, the derivative
might be discontinuous,
and the second derivative
would have a delta function.
So the second derivative
But if the function is
not even continuous,
the second derivative would have
derivatives of delta functions.
So somehow the potential
would have to have that.
And we don't want it.
So to simplify our life, we say
that sine must be continuous.
Now if sine is
continuous, we will
consider several possibilities,
possibilities for V,
possibilities for V of x.
So first possibility--
one, V is continuous.
So psi is continuous,
and V is continuous.
If psi is continuous
and V is continuous,
this product is continuous.
Psi double prime is continuous.
And psi prime is continuous.
Two, V has finite jumps.
Well, if V has finite jumps,
and psi is continuous,
this product has finite jumps.
So psi double prime
has finite jumps.
If psi prime has
finite jumps, the worst
is that psi prime still
must be continuous.
But it changes.
Psi prime could look like
that, could have a corner.
But it cannot be
worse than that.
Because if V has finite
jumps, if psi double
prime has finite jumps, and if
psi prime is not continuous,
it would have delta functions.
So for these two conditions,
continuous or even
finite jumps, psi prime
is still continuous.
Things change qualitatively if
three, V has delta functions.
If V has a delta
function, then psi
double prime has
a delta function.
And psi prime therefore jumps.
Psi prime is not continuous.
Psi prime jumps.
This may be reminiscent
to you whenever
you had to solve the
problem of a bound state
of a delta function,
you got a wave function
that looked like this in
which psi prime jumps.
And it has to jump.
Because psi double prime
has a delta function.
Another case in
which psi prime jumps
is for if V has a hard wall.
That is, the potential suddenly
at one point becomes infinite,
and it prevents the
particle from moving across.
A hard wall is a
place, as you remember
in the infinite square
well, in which the wave
function vanishes, but the
derivative doesn't vanish.
So you could say that
psi is 0 here outside.
Psi prime, then, jumps
in that it's non-0 here
and it's 0 afterwards.
So now, you could
object to what I'm
saying by explaining that,
well, we shouldn't talk
about the wave function
beyond the hard wall.
And in some sense, you're right.
But suppose we do and we say
the wave function is just
0 everywhere, we see
that psi prime jumps.
So really, psi prime jumps.
So this is as bad
as things can get.
So we can summarize this
in just one sentence.
And the sentence reads,
psi and psi prime
are continuous unless V has
delta functions or hard walls,
in which case psi prime
can have finite jumps.
So basically, psi and
psi prime, continuous.
Exceptions-- delta functions
and hard walls, and psi prime
can change.
So questions.
There was a question before.
Maybe it's still there.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you absolutely
need that function [INAUDIBLE]?
Or do we just assume
that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: We assume it--
so the question is, do I
need that in absolute generality
to do quantum mechanics?
I don't think so.
I presume you could discuss
some potentials that
lead to psi that
are not continuous
and still make sense.
But we will not discuss them.
And actually, I don't think
I've encountered any of those.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
give an example
of a physical system whose
potential is well approximated
by a delta function [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, there
are systems like that.
For example, this one
that is somewhat well
approximated by
a delta function.
For example, a
nucleus sometimes is
considered to be like a
spherical cavity in which
particles are bound by a deep
potential and don't escape.
So the nuclei are moving
like that and don't escape.
In that case, it would be
a three dimensional delta
function that vanishes
at the origin.
I presume there
are many examples.
Any potential that
sort of begins
like a finite square well
that is sufficiently deep
will start to look like a
delta function after awhile.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, it's again
neither-- yeah, I guess so.
But it depends how
big is this psi.
So yeah, probably you're right.
This looks a little more like
an analog of a hard wall.
But if a hard wall is
very narrow and very deep,
it looks like a delta function.
So it's idealizations for sure.
But I'm sure we could
get a better example.
And I'll try to find one.
Now, the next
thing we want to do
is give you intuition for
this incredible result
that there's no degeneratives
in one dimensional potentials.
That is not to say that the
proof is not good enough.
It is just to say that
we can illustrate that
without going into a
mathematical proof that
is more complicated.
So how do we do that?
We'll consider the following
case, a simple case,
an example of a
potential of this form.
V of x-- this is x.
And here is V of x.
And we will try to find a
solution with some energy that
is like that, an energy that is
right there below the barrier.
So this would be a bound state.
Why?
Because solutions
here are exponentials
that decay,
exponentials that decay.
And here, the wave
function would
be oscillating presumably.
So the wave functions
go to 0 and infinity.
You could get a bound state.
So let's see how we
get a bound state.
Now, the argument
I'm going to follow
is just an elaboration
of something
you can read in Shankar.
And it's a nice and
simple argument.
So we want to understand why we
would get here no degeneracies.
Or even more-- in fact
not just no degeneracies,
but the spectrum is quantized.
That is, you find one energy,
and then another energy maybe,
and another energy.
So how do we see that?
Well, you look at the way
you can write solutions
and count the parameters
of the solutions
and try to see how many
conditions you have to satisfy.
So here, the wave function
would be a decay in exponential.
A decay in exponential
is of the form
alpha e to the K, kappa, x.
Because x here is negative.
So this decays as x
goes to minus infinity
if kappa is positive.
And that's how a solution looks.
You need one coefficient here
to determine this solutions.
So I'll put a 1 here.
Now, in here, the
solution is oscillatory.
So it's a sine plus cosine.
So you need two coefficients.
In here, the solution
must again be decaying.
And therefore, you just
need one coefficient.
Again, this time it would
be a beta e to the minus Kx.
The fact that this
potential looks
symmetric-- I'm
not assuming it is.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Won't one
of the coefficients
be unconstrained
by normalization?
Isn't one just the
normalization factor?
PROFESSOR: OK, how
about normalization?
Indeed, we have one,
two, and two and one, so
a total of four coefficients,
four parameters.
But indeed, suppose you
wrote your whole solution.
You could say, look, let me
divide this solution by 3.
That's an equivalent solution.
I'm just checking if it solves
the Schrodinger equation.
That's all I have to check.
I don't have to
check normalization.
Normalization, in fact, is
sort of irrelevant here.
You just need to know
if a bound state exists.
So indeed, even though you have
these four parameters, given
that you can multiply the
solution by a constant,
there's just three
constants to fix.
Four parameters
via normalization
or the multiplication by
any constant-- just three
constants to fix.
But this potential
is nice enough
that psi and psi prime
must be continuous.
So you get two conditions
here and two conditions here.
So four conditions-- continuity
of psi and psi prime,
continuity of psi and psi
prime, four conditions.
So what did we get?
We got in trouble.
We've shown that this is
unsolvable in general.
Because there are more
conditions than parameters.
Now, this equation could
to be a little peculiar.
Maybe this is not
completely general.
But you seem to have more
conditions than parameters.
But here comes the catch.
The solution really
is determined.
Like kappa-- do you know kappa?
Well, you know kappa if you
know the energy of the solution.
Kappa is determined by the
energy of the solution.
So some parameters in the
solution depend on the energy.
So the way we have
to think of this
is that in fact three constants
to fix, but four conditions.
So we really need
four constants to fix.
And the fourth
constant is the energy.
So the energy is the
fourth constant to fix.
And with four conditions,
these three constants
that we had there and the
energy, they can just be fixed.
So the solution
should fix the energy
and should fix this coefficient.
So the solution exists for
some energy, or possibly
some values of the energies, but
not all values of the energy.
So this shows, or at least
very clearly illustrates,
that you are going to find sets
of energies for which you have
solutions depending on
how the equations look,
and one solution each time.
So you get what is called
a discrete non-degenerate
spectrum.
Now, there are more
cases to discuss,
the case in which you
have just the step,
or the case in which you
have three bound states.
And I will not do them
but state the results.
Again, all that I
don't do explicitly
can be found in the notes.
So you would look at them later.
And so here is the second
case, a potential like this
and an energy like
that, energy level.
And what you get here is that
in fact, doing the counting
and analyzing the
boundary conditions,
you should do it by yourselves.
But you will see the
answers in the notes.
You get here continuous
spectrum, non-degenerate.
So you will get a
solution for every value
of the energy-- that's to mean,
continuous spectrum-- and one
solution each time.
Finally, this case-- if you
have an energy like this,
e, you get continuous spectrum
and doubly degenerate,
so two solutions.
Now, after this,
there's one more result
that qualifies as a theorem.
And it's hard to
prove rigorously.
I will not attempt to prove
it here nor even in the notes.
It's hard enough.
So this theorem has
to do with nodes.
Theorem-- so if you have
the discrete bound state
spectrum of a one
dimensional potential,
and you list the energies
E1 less than E2 less than E3
like that, E1 is the
ground state energy.
Remember, this
spectrum is discrete.
So this is less than
E2, less than E3,
and it goes on like that,
the ground state energy.
Then, you have associated wave
functions, energy eigenstates
psi 1 of x, psi 2
of x, psi 3 of x.
Here is the theorem.
The theorem tells you something
about the vanishing of the wave
function.
It says that psi 1 has no nodes.
Psi 2 has one node.
Psi 3 has two nodes.
And so it goes so that psi
n has n minus one node.
So psi n is greater
than-- well, it's correct.
Any n greater or equal
to 1 has n minus 1 nodes.
Now, there are several
ways people show this.
Mathematicians show it in
a rather delicate analysis.
Physicists have an
argument as well
for this, which is based on
approximating any potential
by infinite square
wells to begin with.
So suppose you have a
potential like that.
Well, think of it as first being
a little potential like that,
an infinite square well.
And you start making the window
of the square well bigger.
The argument-- it's
a neat argument.
Maybe you can discuss
it in recitation.
I would suggest that.
It's a good argument.
But it's not rigorous.
But still, one can do
something like that.
You make it grow.
And what you know is that
the infinite square well,
the first wave
function has no node.
And as you change the screen to
make the potential really what
it's supposed to be and not
just that of a square well,
the wave function
cannot gain a node.
On the other hand, what you
will show in the homework
is something that is
a partial result which
says that the
solution with n plus 1
has at least one more node
than the solution with n.
So it's part of
what you can show.
And it doesn't take
too much effort.
And you can prove it rigorously.
So we will assign
that eventually
for a homework to do.
In the homework that you
have for the first homework,
you also have a problem
with delta functions.
And I suggest that you
read the notes that
will be posted today.
Because there's an example
there with delta functions.
If you study that
example, you'll
find the problem
quite easy to solve.
You may have solved already.
Some of you are very eager to
get going with the homework.
So it's something you
can study first, and then
make your life a little easier.
So what we're going to do now
for the rest of the lecture
is consider the
variational problem, which
is something you probably
haven't seen before,
the variational problem.
This problem has to do with
calculus of variations.
Now, calculus of
variations is something
considered fairly advanced.
And therefore, as
you will see, we
will avoid some of the major
difficulties of calculus
of variations in our discussion
of the variational principle.
But I wanted to mention a
little story about this problem.
So this calculus of variations
is a more complicated version
of maxima and minima in which in
maxima and minima of functions
you look at the function.
And if you could plot it, you
could say, here's a maximum,
here's a minimum.
If you want to figure out
where they are, you know.
You take a derivative,
set it equal to 0,
you find the maxima and minima.
So the typical
calculus problem is
one in which you
have a function,
and you want the
maxima and minima.
The variational
problem is a problem
in which you want to maximize
or minimize something.
But what you don't know is not
where the maximum or minimum
occurs, but which
kind of function
will give you this
maximum or minimum.
So your unknown is
not a point where
there's a maximum or a
minimum but a function where
there is a maximum
and a minimum.
So it's slightly
more complicated.
So this is the
calculus of variations.
And people wonder
when did it start.
It actually seems to have
first been discussed by Newton.
And it's quite an
interesting story.
Newton was trying to
understand apparently
the following problem.
If you would have a cross
sectional area like this,
he asked the question,
how should you
make a solid out of this
by tapering it and ending
with this, tapering
it, in such a way
that as it moves
in a viscous fluid,
the resistance is the minimum
possible-- very complicated
problem.
And as you can imagine, this
is a complicated problem
because you're trying to find
a shape-- not just a maximum
or a minimum of a
function but what
shape maximizes
or minimizes this.
So apparently, he
solved the problem
and wrote it in Principia but
didn't explain his solution.
And people for years were
trying to figure it out.
And nobody could figure
out how he did it.
Then, the story goes that this
mathematician Johann Bernoulli
in 1696 came up with a
challenge to all mathematicians.
At that time, people
would announce a problem
and challenge to
see who's smart,
who can solve this problem.
So Johann Bernoulli
in around 1696
poses a problem of, you're
given two points in the plane,
in the vertical plane like
this blackboard, point this, A,
and point B in here.
You must design the
curve of shortest time
for fall, so some curve here.
If you put an object
and let it fall,
it will get the fastest
to that point, so maybe
something that looks like this.
It's a complicated curve, or
at least not all that simple.
And he asked all the
people to solve it,
gave them one year to solve it.
So who was around at that time?
Well, one person that got
the letter was Leibniz.
He got it on the 9th of
June of that year, 1696.
And he answered it,
sent an email back,
by the 16th of
June with a letter
with a complete solution.
It's a funny thing that actually
apparently Newton was very busy
and didn't receive this letter.
Or something happened,
and he got it one day,
and he actually solved
the problem in one night.
It took him one full
night to solve it.
Now, you say, well,
how brilliant.
And true, but given that
he had solved this problem,
he was criticized as being
really slow and-- how come
you took 12 hours to
solve this problem?
So it's quite amazing.
There's a lot of Bernoullis.
And apparently, this
question by Jacob Bernoulli,
the main purpose
of this question
was to demonstrate to everybody
that his older brother,
Jacob Bernoulli, who had
invented the Bernoulli numbers,
was actually an
incompetent person that
could not solve this problem.
So that was apparently
what he wanted to do.
It's a rather famous family.
But they obviously
didn't get along.
But apparently, Jacob did
manage to solve the problem.
So Jacob Bernoulli, Leibniz, and
Newton all solved the problem.
Johann Bernoulli, the one that
started this problem-- and I
think it's maybe
with a double N,
I'm sorry-- his son
is Daniel Bernoulli.
And engineers know
him, because that's
the Bernoulli of the Bernoulli
fluid dynamics stuff.
So the problem is
not all that easy.
And calculus of variations
determines this shape.
So the calculus of variation
applied to quantum mechanics
asks, here, this function is
determined by the principle
that it minimizes time.
So you have the
Schrodinger Equation.
And you could ask, you have
all these Eigenfunctions.
What do they minimize?
Is there something
they're minimize?
And the answer is yes.
And this is what
you'll understand
in the next few minutes.
So what is the problem
we want to solve?
We want to solve the
problem h psi equal e psi.
So some Hamiltonian.
Now my notation
will be such that it
applies to three
dimensions as well.
So I'll put just
arrows on top of it,
and you would have to write
the proper Hamiltonian.
It will not be necessary for
you to know the Hamiltonian.
So I'll put psi
of x here, meaning
that this is equally valid
for more than one dimension.
Now we want to find
solutions of this equation.
And you can say, what do
they maximize or minimize?
Well we won't get to
it until 15 minutes.
First let's try
something simpler.
How about, can we
learn something
about the ground state
energy of the system?
So let's try to think about
the ground state energy.
State energy.
Now consider ground
state energy and we'll
consider an
arbitrary-- arbitrary
is the most
important word here--
psi of x that is normalized.
Is normalized.
So integral the x of psi
squared is equal to 1.
And here comes the claim.
The first claim
that we can make.
You see, this wave
function doesn't
solve the Schrodinger equation.
That's what we
mean by arbitrary.
It's just any function of
space that is normalizable.
Doesn't solve the
Schrodinger equation.
Never the less,
you are commanded
to compute the
following quantity.
This quantity is
also by definition
what we call the
expectation value
of the Hamiltonian
in the state psi.
I love the fact, the
remarkable fact that we're
going to show now, is
that this thing provides
an upper bound for the ground
state energy for all psi.
So let me try to make
sure we understand
what's happening here.
Here it says you don't know
the ground state energy
but you're going to
learn something about it.
Something that's
interesting is if you
know that it has an upper bound,
so the ground state energy
is definitely not
higher than this one,
so you learn something.
Would be ideal if you
had also lower bound
so you knew it's in this range.
But an upper bound is
a nice thing to have.
And the claim here is that
each time you try an arbitrary
function, you put anything
here, you ever write,
you've got an upper bound.
So how is this used?
You try arbitrary functions
that you think look possibly
like the wave function
of a bound state.
And you get numbers
and you already
know that the ground
state energy smaller
than some number.
So it's a rather nice way
of getting some information
about the ground state energy.
So this psi effects is
called a trial wave function.
Is a trial wave function.
So is the statement
of this theorem clear?
Not the proof,
but the statement.
Do we have questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
statement about how
using the wave
function will give us
how accurate an
estimate [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
We're going to become
good and figure out
some nice way of choosing
wave functions, but no.
Once you tried you
got some information.
And you may not know
so easily whether you
could go much lower.
You can try a little, but
there's no clear way to know.
This is just some
partial information.
OK.
So let me first prove this.
We'll prove it and then explain
a little more what it all
means.
So the proof.
Now it's a proof
under quotation marks.
I will make a few assumptions.
Basically, that I don't
have a continuous spectrum.
Now that assumption is done for
me to write a simpler proof,
not because the
result doesn't hold.
So the proof is
good, but I will just
consider for notational
purposes no continuous spectrum.
So we'll have a
ground state energy
which is e1 that is maybe less
than or equal to e2 less than
or equal e3 like that.
So you even may consider
the [? genorisies. ?]
And we have h psi n
is equal to en psi n.
So what do we have?
We have a trial wave function.
So your trial wave
function since it's
an arbitrary
function of x should
be expandable by completeness
as a serious or a superb
position of the
energy eigenstates.
Let me clarify this point.
This is a trial wave function.
Doesn't solve the
Schrodinger equation.
So this Doesn't solve this
energy eigenstate equation.
So in fact, it doesn't
solve it because this
is a superb position
of many in here.
So that's consistent
with this, and the fact
that this wave function
as given in here
just can be represented
using the energy eigenstates.
But being a superb
position, it's
not an energy eigenstate which
is true because a trial wave
function is something that
you invent out of your head.
It's not a solution.
If you had a solution,
you wouldn't need this.
So you don't have a solution.
You invent the trial wave
function, and you have this.
A couple of things.
The psi squared
integral being one.
You can do that
integral, that condition,
is the sum of their
bn-2nd is equal to 1.
This I use the orthonormality.
You can elevate this.
It's sort of the kinds of
things we're doing last time.
Please make sure you
know how to do that.
Then there's the
other computation
that we also have
sketched last time, which
is that the integral
of psi star h
psi which is what
we want to compute,
h hat psi is actually bn-2nd en.
So that was
something we're doing
towards the end of last lecture.
And this computation takes a
few lines, but it was there.
It's in the notes.
And now comes the kind
of thing we want to say.
Look at this sum.
It has b1, e1, b2, e2,
b3, e3, but e2, e3, e4,
all those are bigger,
or at most, equal to e1.
So if I did, here,
the following bad joke
of substituting en for e1, which
is not the same, if I put here
bn squared n equals
1 to infinity.
I put here e1,
well this is bigger
than that because e2 is
possibly bigger than e1,
e3 is bigger than e1.
But it may be equal.
But at this moment, e1
can go out of the sum.
So this is e1 times
this sum which
is 1 because bn is equal to 1.
And e1 is the ground state
energy by definition.
So the ground state
energy is less
than this which
is the expectation
value of the Hamiltonian.
Pretty simple, in
fact, the proof
is really a little too simple.
Where do we go from now?
Well let's make a
more general statement
of the variational principal.
Again, sometimes
it's not all that
convenient to have
normalized wave functions.
So recall that if psi
of x is not normalized,
psi of x over the square root
of integral of psi-2nd dx is.
Therefore if you
hand me an arbitrary
psi of x that is
really arbitrary.
You don't even bother
to normalize it.
Then when I plug
here in this formula
it is supposed to be normalized.
So I plug the second
expression there.
So therefore I get
that egs less than
or equal to the
integral of psi star h
psi the x over integral
of psi star psi the x.
This is actually
nicer in one way
because you don't have to work
with normalized wave functions.
And that result
must be true still.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sure.
It cannot be
completely arbitrary,
the function should
we normalizable.
Doesn't have to be
normalized but normalizable.
So here you got.
And here let me introduce
just a little name.
f of psi.
f of psi is what is
called a functional.
f of is a functional.
What is a functional?
A functional is a
machine or an expression
whose input is a function
and whose output is a number.
So here f of psi
is a functional.
And maybe I should use brackets.
Many times people with brackets
denote that, watch out,
this is not a function,
it's a functional.
And here it is.
No dash there.
You give me a psi of
x, which is a function,
and then this is a
number because you've
done the integrals.
So that is like the
Brachistochrone problem, that
a funny name for it.
Here it is.
There is a function
now which is the time
that it takes to go here.
You give me a path,
a function, and I
can calculate the time it will
take the mass to get here.
So this was the issue of
finding a critical point
of a functional.
So actually we start to see,
it seems that the ground state
energy is the minimum
of this functional.
And what this
interesting as well
is that when you get the
minimum you will have gotten
a ground state wave function.
So the ground state
wave function actually
is the thing that
minimizes this functional
and gives you some value,
the ground state energy.
A little more in a
couple of minutes.
Let's do an example.
How do we use this so now if
you think about this carefully
it's kind of dizzying because
what is sell functional,
really?
It's, in some sense, a function
in an infinite dimensional
space because a function
itself is specified
by infinitely many numbers
that you can change.
So how many dimensions
you have is how many ways
you can move your hands, but
they are linearly independent.
But if you have a function,
and you can change it,
you can change it here,
you can change it there,
or you can change it
there, and those are all
orthogonal directions.
You're finding a critical point.
When you find the
critical point,
you should imagine that you're
plotting a function that is not
one dimensional function or
two dimensional function,
but it's infinitely
dimensional function.
Direction one, direction two,
infinitely many directions.
And suddenly in this
infinitely many directions
you find the critical point.
It's really incredible that
one can do these things.
So you're at that
critical point,
and you can deform
the energy eigenstate
by making it a little
fatter here or thinner
here or up there.
And those are the
infinite directions
in any direction that
you will the energy
goes up because you're
at the global minimum
it's pretty amazing.
Something that you will
prove in the homework
is that actually it's even more.
Every single eigenstate
is a critical point
of this functional.
So you've got the
lowest energy state
and in that infinite dimensional
space in every direction
that you move you go up.
The first excited state
is another critical point.
But it will not be
an absolute minimum.
It will be a [? saddle ?]
an infinite dimensional
[? saddle ?] which
are infinitely
many directions in
which you go up.
There's one direction
in which you go down
because you could flow
towards the ground state.
So the first excited state
is the [? saddle ?] but these
are all stationary points
of this functional.
So we'll conclude by
doing this example.
Sorry, what is the question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I didn't assume
it's non-degenerate.
So if you have two things that
have the same ground state,
the functional will have, in
fact, the degeneracy there
will be two solutions
that have the same energy.
And any linear combination of
them will have the same energy.
The proof that I did here
doesn't assume non-degeneracy,
it's even true with
degenerate things.
So the example is an
example for illustration,
not for solving something
that you can't do otherwise.
So it's a delta
function potential.
v of x is minus alpha delta
of x with alpha positive.
And the ground state
energy is well known.
It's minus m alpha
squared over 2h-2nd.
You've solved this
problem many times in 804.
So trial wave function.
Well you know how
it should look,
but let's assume you don't.
And you say, it's some
sort of [INAUDIBLE].
So trial.
It would be psi of x equals
e to the minus x squared.
While this would do,
you're going to work hard
and you're not going to
reap all the benefits
of this calculation.
So what you should do at this
moment is put a constant here.
Minus beta squared x squared
and I'll put the minus one half.
This is our trial wave function.
You see, by this, you're
going to get an expression.
You calculate this
number, and you're
going to get the
function of beta.
Beta is not going to disappear.
And therefore, you're going
to know that the ground state
energy is less than
this function of beta.
And then you can adjust
beta to get the best bound.
So beta is put as a
parameter to begin with,
and we hope to use it.
So note that integral of
psi squared dx in this case
is equal to square
root of pi over beta.
So we have to calculate
this whole functional.
So this integral
of psi star-- well
I don't have to bother with
psi star because it's real.
h psi over psi psi,
and what do we get?
Well the denominator is easy.
So we beta over
square root of pi,
and let me write the
whole thing here.
dx the psi would have
e to the minus one half
beta squared x squared
minus h squared
over 2m d-2nd dx2nd
minus alpha delta of x.
And another wave function,
e to the minus one
half beta squared x-2nd.
OK.
So you have to evaluate that.
And that's the part
that is not so much fun.
For any integral
that you have in 805,
we believe that you can use
Mathematica or Maple or MATLAB
or whatever and do it.
The only reason not to
use any of these things
is if you think you could
not do the integral.
But once you realize,
oh, this is an integral,
I know how to do,
don't waste time.
Use any of those programs.
Now, this part of the
integral is kind of easy
because the delta function
just picks the value of 0.
So this part of the
integral gives you
minus beta alpha over
square root of pi.
The other part of the
integral, however,
is a little more complicated.
Believe it or not, it
makes a big difference
whether you take
the two derivatives
of this function or
you integrate by parts.
If you integrate by parts,
you save a lot of work.
So let me integrate by parts.
This becomes, plus beta
over square root of h,
h-2nd over 2m,
integral dx of ddx of e
to the minus one half beta
squared x-2nd squared.
So you integrate by
parts one of the ddx
and then you have the other
ddx, so it's the thing squared.
And that's an easier
integral to do.
We don't want to
bother with this,
but this whole
thing then becomes
minus beta over square root of
pi, alpha plus beta squared h
squared over 4m.
That's the whole
answer And that's
the valuation of
this whole thing.
So look what you get.
You got a function
of beta indeed.
So how does that
function of beta look?
It's 0 for beta equals 0 is 0
for some other possible beta,
it's going to look like this.
So there's a point at
which this function is
going to have a minimum, and
we should choose that point
to get the best upper
bound on the function.
Our claim is that following
from the variational theorem
that we've proven
is that the e ground
state is less than or equal
than the minimum value over beta
of this beta squared
h squared over 4m
minus beta square
root of pie alpha.
So you minimize over beta,
and yet still the ground state
energy must be a little
smaller than that.
Well what do you get?
You do this, this minimization
gives beta equal 2m
alpha over h squared
square root of pi.
It's a little messy
but not terrible.
And you substitute, and you
get that e ground state is
less than or equal than m alpha
squared over pi h squared.
And to better write it as 2
over pi times minus m alpha
squared over 2h-2nd which is
the true ground state energy.
So let's just make sure we
understand what has happened.
Here is the energy.
Here is zero.
Energy as just a vertical
plot here is zero.
The true ground state
energy of this problem
is this one, let's call
it egs, is negative.
And we go 2 over pi times that.
2 over pi is about 0.64.
So the bound says
that here is 0.64 egs.
So that's what the
bound told you.
The bound state energy must
be lower than this quantity.
We got close.
Not impressively
close, but the work
functional was not
all that bad either.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
always going
to be a constant times
incorrect energy value
or is it just the
closest approximation?
PROFESSOR: Is it
going to be what?
AUDIENCE: Is it
always going to be
a constant times the correct
energy value or is it just--
PROFESSOR: Well it
typically is like that
because of dimensional units.
You're looking for a
constant because you're not
looking for the function.
So you will get a number times
a correct value, yes, indeed.
That's an illustration of the
problem of wave functions.
You know the variational
principle tells you
things about the
ground state but allows
you to find the first
excited state as well
if the potential is symmetric,
will allow you to prove
that any attractive
potential has a bound state.
And you will prove
in the homework
that stationary points of these
things are the eigenfunctions.
See you next Monday.